foreign is Keen to support Ukraine in
its war with Russia
here soldiers train Ukrainian recruits
in the UK but underfunded and facing
further cuts the British army is in need
of help too and defense ministers appear
to agree
the cereal under investment in the Army
over decades has led to the point where
the Army is in urgent need of
recapitalization the charts around the
Prime Minister get that and there's a
budget coming
his boss knows there are challenges but
says he has a plan to reverse the
decline what we're seeing now is the
consequences of hollowing urge and you
know as a defense secretary I've always
said I'm not going to pretend things are
perfect I'm not going to sort of say
look over here look at the red arrows
and shoot me the color I'm going to
actually say that's what's going on
behind the scenes and we're going to try
and fix it
came after Sky News revealed that a U.S
general had said the British army is no
longer regarded as a top level fighting
force
opposition politicians were scathing
about the downgrade even though past
labor governments were also to blame I
think it's very concerning that these
are the conversations that our allies
are having around UK forces I think it
also raises some very serious questions
about whether the government can be
trusted to look after our defense and
security at such a critical time Rishi
sunak defended his record but all eyes
will be on whether he decides to give
any more money to the military in his
spring budget when I was Chancellor we
increased funding in the armed forces by
a record amount as well because we
wanted we recognize that the world had
changed and was becoming a less safe
place and that needed extra resourcing
so that's gone in and again we need to
make sure that goes on all the right
things but that's what we're doing the
Prime Minister rightly says that back in
2020 the government injected an extra 16
billion pounds into defense but what's
not mentioned is that wasn't as much as
the military had been asking for to plug
capability gaps since then you've had
the war here in Ukraine increased
security threats and A Renewed sense of
urgency that the Army can't be allowed
to break with Russia's War still raging
defense sources say they hope the Prime
Minister will agree debraham Sky News
Kiev